Here's the story the way we usually like it. There's this guy, and he's behind enemy lines. Maybe he's dropped in there in the middle of the night, maybe he sneaks under barbed wire at the border, whatever. He's there. He's been there a while. Months, years maybe. He's in disguise, working on our behalf. Nobody suspects. No one can tell. He looks and acts just like them.
这就是我们通常喜欢讲述的故事：有一个人身处敌后。也许他是半夜空投进去的，也许是从边境铁丝网下潜入的，不管怎样，他就在那儿。他待了一段时间，几个月，也许几年。他乔装打扮，为我们工作。没人怀疑，没人认得出来。他的外貌和行为举止都和他们一模一样。
And then, living there in their midst for so long, speaking the language, eating their food, breathing their air, watching their TV shows, something happens. He starts to change. He starts to become more like them. And then, when it's time for him to strike, to launch his mission against them, he hesitates. He's not sure who he sympathizes with anymore.
然后，他在那里生活了那么久，说着他们的语言，吃着他们的食物，呼吸着他们的空气，看着他们的电视节目，事情发生了变化。他开始改变，变得越来越像他们。接着，当他该出击、执行针对他们的任务时，他犹豫了。他不再确定自己到底同情哪一方。
It's a very romantic idea, this particular vision of what it means to live inside the enemy camp. That you lose your bearings and you would forget how to fight because some other impulse inside you would take over. But sometimes this is actually how it happens. There are lots of ways that people get confused about who their enemy is and how to fight them. Today on our radio show we have that story happening to several different people in several different places in several different ways. True stories.
这种关于生活在敌营中的独特愿景，是非常浪漫的想法。你会失去方向感，忘记如何战斗，因为内心会有另一种冲动占据主导。但有时事实确实如此。人们在辨别敌人是谁以及如何与他们战斗时，有很多感到困惑的方式。今天在我们的电台节目中，我们就带来了几个不同的人在不同地点以不同方式经历这种故事。真实的故事。
WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program we choose some subject, bring you documentaries, interviews, short fiction, found tapes, found writing, anything we can think of on that subject.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》，由美国公共广播国际（PRI）发行。我是主持人艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来纪录片、访谈、短篇小说、发现的录音带、发现的文字，或者任何我们能想到的关于该主题的内容。
Today on our program, life behind enemy lines. Our program today in four acts. Act one, Our Own Worst Enemy? In that act, even senior administration officials like Colin Powell now admit that the insurgency in Iraq is getting stronger. We get one of the architects of the president's war in Iraq, Richard Perle, to answer the question, is it our own fault that things are going so badly in Iraq.
今天我们的节目主题是：敌后生活。今天我们的节目分为四幕。第一幕，《我们最大的敌人？》。在这一幕中，就连像科林·鲍威尔这样的高级行政官员现在也承认，伊拉克的叛乱正在加强。我们请到了总统伊拉克战争的策划者之一理查德·珀尔，来回答一个问题：事情在伊拉克变得如此糟糕，是我们自己的错吗？
Act two, Confession. In that act, the true story of a fixer for the Catholic Church and how he came to sympathize with people who he was sent by the church to deceive. Act three, Blood Agent. How microscopic beings inside you and me can control our thoughts and minds, no kidding. Act four, sleeping with the enemy. In which we ask the question, whose side is your girlfriend on, anyway? Whose? Stay with us.
第二幕，《忏悔》。在这一幕中，是一个天主教会“清理人”的真实故事，讲述他如何对他被教会派去欺骗的人产生了同情。第三幕，《血液代理人》。微小的生物是如何潜入你我体内控制我们的思想和心灵的，这不是开玩笑。第四幕，《与敌同眠》。在这一幕中，我们要问这样一个问题：你的女朋友到底站在哪一边？哪一边？请继续收听。
Hi.
你好。
Greetings. Think we met once in the distant past.
你好。我想我们在很久以前见过一面。
Yeah, we did. Hi.
是的，确实见过。你好。
So Richard Perle and James Fellows. The question that we wanted to talk to the two of you about it is, once we decided to go to war, did the administration do a competent job in planning and executing it? Basically, how good are they at their jobs at conducting the war on terror.
理查德·珀尔和詹姆斯·法洛斯，我们想和你们两位讨论的问题是，一旦我们决定开战，政府在规划和执行方面做得称职吗？基本上，他们在进行反恐战争方面的表现如何？
And there's a whole list of now familiar charges. Inadequate planning for post-war Iraq, not having enough troops to control the country after the war, the war getting worse each month. Richard Perle, are they doing a good job?
现在有一长串大家都很熟悉的指控。战后伊拉克的规划不足，战争结束后没有足够的部队来控制该国，战争每月都在恶化。理查德·珀尔，他们表现得好吗？
I think the administration is doing about as good a job as they can do under the circumstances. Which is not to say it's a great job. I don't think it is. I think a lot of mistakes have been made. And we learn with every mistake.
我认为政府在目前的情况下已经尽力做得不错了。但这并不是说做得很好。我不认为做得很好。我认为犯了很多错误。而且我们在每一个错误中学习。
Are there certain mistakes that you think were avoidable?
你认为有些错误是可以避免的吗？
Well, the single largest mistake in my view was in not going into Iraq with a significant number of Iraqis at our side. In not handing authority over more or less immediately after the fall of Baghdad.
嗯，在我看来，最大的单一错误在于没有带上大量的伊拉克人站在我们这边进入伊拉克。在于没有在巴格达陷落后立即移交权力。
You criticize the planning. In fact, there was extensive planning. It wasn't always right. But I don't know anyone who, in a situation largely without precedent, can be expected to get everything right.
你批评了规划。事实上，当时有广泛的规划。它并不总是正确的。但我不知道在一种基本没有先例的情况下，有谁能被要求做到事事正确。
James Fallows, what's your take on this?
詹姆斯·法洛斯，你对此有何看法？
Well I have to take issue with-- I agree with the assessment that things have not gone very well. On the idea that this was sort of beyond anyone's calculation, I mean, with respect, it's just not true. Most of the expert branches of the government were saying, post-conquest order is the first order of priority. You have to make sure that Iraqis can see that there is stability now that there's a new sheriff in town. There has to be a sense of order. And so this was clearly foreseen and just dismissed.
嗯，我不得不表示异议——我同意事情进展得很不顺利的评估。至于说这超出了任何人的计算，恕我直言，这不是事实。政府中大多数专家部门都在说，征服后的秩序是第一要务。你必须确保伊拉克人能看到，现在有个新警长在城里，局势是稳定的。必须有一种秩序感。所以这一点显然是预见到了，只是被无视了。
And just to be clear, James Fallows, you're saying in your reporting what you found is that the administration was warned specifically about this kind of looting and this kind of disorder starting, and yet didn't get control of the capital and didn't get control of the country.
为了明确起见，詹姆斯·法洛斯，你是说在你的报道中你发现，政府曾明确收到过关于这种抢劫和这种混乱开始的警告，但却没有控制住首都，也没有控制住国家。
I'm saying specifically, and anybody who doubts can go to the Army War College website and check these studies, that it was warned that the thing to start doing on the first day, and certainly in the first three days and the first week, was to guarantee public order. Because the thing that was sure to happen when a repressive regime was unleashed was disorder, and disorder in the early period could be profoundly destabilizing. And this simply was ignored. And it wasn't from some pinko group, it was the US Army War College.
我明确地说，任何人如果怀疑，可以去陆军战争学院的网站上查看这些研究。警告说，第一天，当然是在前三天和第一周，最先要做的事情就是确保公共秩序。因为当一个压迫性政权被解除武装时，肯定会发生混乱，而初期的混乱可能会产生深远的破坏稳定性影响。但这只是被忽视了。这并不是来自什么激进组织，而是美国陆军战争学院的观点。
I'm sorry, it is a big leap from saying that some scholars-- and I don't know who they were-- at the Army War College or at National Defense University or somewhere else prepared a report, and the fact that they prepared a report and there were problems afterward proves that we ignored sensible planning.
抱歉，从说一些学者——我不知道他们是谁——在陆军战争学院或国防大学或其他地方写了一份报告，到他们写了报告而之后出现了问题就证明我们忽视了合理的规划，这中间跨度太大了。
Let me give you two examples of more sort of direct orders. It is now well known that the Army and its Chief of Staff, Eric Shinseki, were saying, you need more people to do this. You need them to secure the borders. You need them to patrol Baghdad, et cetera. That was deliberately, and as you'll recall very high-handedly, rejected by Paul Wolfowitz and Donald Rumsfeld.
让我给你举两个关于更直接命令的例子。现在众所周知，陆军及其参谋长埃里克·新关当时说，你需要更多的人来做这件事。你需要他们来保卫边境。你需要他们去巴格达巡逻，等等。这被保罗·沃尔福威茨和唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德故意——正如你所记得的那样——非常傲慢地拒绝了。
I remember what General Shinseki was saying. And what he was saying, he was talking first of all about the invasion force.
我记得新关将军在说什么。他当时首先谈论的是入侵部队。
With respect, that's not correct. Shinseki was saying you needed them for security after the fall of Baghdad. Shinseki's experience had been in Kosovo and the Balkans, and he said he'd been in charge of peacekeeping there. And he said based on his rules of thumb, you needed one per x thousand of population. I now forget the ratio. But it would have led to about twice as many troops as the US went in with.
恕我直言，那是不对的。新关说的是你需要他们来维持巴格达陷落后的安全。新关的经验是在科索沃和巴尔干地区，他说他曾负责那里的维和工作。他说根据他的经验法则，每一千名人口需要多少兵力。我现在忘了这个比例了。但如果照此执行，兵力大约是美国实际投入兵力的两倍。
Well I certainly agree that we could have done a much better job of establishing order at the beginning. I believe that the way to do that was not by having twice as many Americans on the ground, but by having Iraqis who understood the situation a great deal better than we did.
我当然同意我们在初期可以做得更好来建立秩序。我相信做到这一点的方法不是在地面上有两倍的美国人，而是要有比我们更了解情况的伊拉克人。
But in a sense, I've got to say as a voter, to me it kind of doesn't matter if it should have been Iraqi forces or it should have been more American forces. I feel like all I see is that you both are saying we needed more troops on the ground to make the country more secure at the beginning, and it was one of the most important things that we could do. And that's led to that kind of problems that we're having now, and they get worse and worse and worse.
但从某种意义上说，作为一个选民，我不得不说，对我来说，到底是伊拉克军队还是更多的美军其实并不重要。我觉得我看到的情况是，你们两位都说我们需要更多的地面部队在初期让国家更安全，这是我们能做的最重要的事情之一。而这导致了我们现在遇到的那种问题，而且情况越来越糟糕。
Well no, you're going way beyond anything I said.
好吧，不，你说的远超出了我所说的内容。
OK, how am I going beyond?
好吧，我怎么超出了？
Well first of all, I didn't say we needed more troops. We needed different troops. If we'd had the 10,000 Iraqis who we should have gone in with, I think we would have been in much better shape. And in particular, I think the looting and the early signs of disintegration-- I think our military commanders misunderstood the implications of the looting. And if you're unhappy with the way that mission was handled, you should be talking to the battlefield commander.
首先，我没说需要更多的军队。我们需要的是不同的军队。如果我们带了我们本应该带上的那10,000名伊拉克人，我认为我们的处境会好得多。特别是，我认为我们的军事指挥官误解了抢劫的含义。如果你对任务处理的方式不满意，你应该去和战场指挥官谈谈。
From the public's point of view, it doesn't really matter at what stage the breakdown was. We are agreeing that something seriously has gone wrong, and do we blame the military or do we blame the civilian leaders of the military?
从公众的角度来看，崩溃发生在哪个阶段其实并不重要。我们都同意事情确实出了严重的问题，我们是该责怪军队还是该责怪军队的文职领导人？
Well, you can assign responsibility but I wouldn't call it blame. Because this is something we do every day. We're learning.
嗯，你可以分配责任，但我不会称之为“责怪”。因为这是我们每天都在做的事情。我们在学习。
You say that we don't do this every day. In fact, the US has carried out a lot of occupations from the Philippines onward, and none of them has gone as badly as this. Preparing for this sort of thing would have meant it was taken more time, either to bring more American troops there or to get a bigger alliance. Whether European, whether Arab, or whatever. And so all of these warnings were at odds with the idea of getting the war going sooner rather than later.
你说我们没有每天都这样做。事实上，美国从菲律宾开始进行过多次占领，没有一次像这次一样糟糕。为这种事情做准备意味着需要花费更多的时间，无论是带更多的美军到那里，还是建立一个更大的联盟。无论是欧洲的、阿拉伯的，还是其他什么的。所以所有这些警告都与那种想尽早而不是晚点发动战争的想法相冲突。
Let's move on to a different subject. One thing that's come up in the two debates is this question of letting Osama bin Laden get away at Tora Bora. It's been brought up in both of the debates so far. Neither the president nor the vice president actually responded directly to the charge. It seems really damning.
让我们谈谈另一个话题。在两场辩论中出现的一件事是关于让奥萨马·本·拉登在托拉博拉逃脱的问题。这个问题在迄今为止的两场辩论中都被提到了。无论是总统还是副总统都没有直接回应这一指控。这看起来真的很具破坏性。
The suggestion somehow seems to be that the president of the United States or the vice president should have been commanding US forces in Afghanistan at a level of detail that is absurd. The troops in the field who were responsible for handling the situation were not taking direct orders from the president of the United States.
这种暗示似乎是美国总统或副总统应该以一种荒谬的细节程度指挥阿富汗的美军。负责处理这种情况的前线部队并非直接接受美国总统的命令。
I think this is a slight mischaracterization of what the critique is. It's not that Bush or Cheney should have been picking targets the way Lyndon Johnson did. Instead it's two fundamental points. One is that the assignment for the crucial part of this pincer movement was given on the one hand to the Afghan quote, "warlords", unquote on the other side of the border to the Pakistanis, as opposed to being under direct control. There also was clearly a shift in the center of gravity of attention within the Pentagon by early 2002, just around the time of Tora Bora, towards Iraq and away from Afghanistan.
我认为这稍微歪曲了批评的本质。并不是说布什或切尼应该像林登·约翰逊那样挑选目标。相反，这是两个基本点。一是这次钳形运动关键部分的分配，一方面交给了边境另一侧的阿富汗“军阀”，而不是处于直接控制之下。另一点是，到2002年初，也就是托拉博拉时期，五角大楼注意力的重心显然转移到了伊拉克，而远离了阿富汗。
Richard Perle?
理查德·珀尔？
I think it's easy to second guess what went wrong at Tora Bora. The judgment was made that certain parts of that military operation were best handled by Afghans. I can see reasons why people would come to that conclusion. It may not have been the right conclusion, I don't know. But it certainly was not the case that either the president was making the decision at that tactical level, nor I believe is it fair to say that that would have been handled differently if we had not been at that point planning for the operations in Iraq.
我认为事后诸葛亮去谈托拉博拉哪里出了问题很容易。当时做出的判断是，那场军事行动的某些部分最好由阿富汗人来处理。我可以理解人们得出这一结论的原因。这可能不是正确的结论，我不知道。但肯定不是说总统在那个战术层面做出了决定，我也认为如果当时我们没有在计划伊拉克行动，情况就会得到不同的处理，这种说法是不公平的。
Richard Perle, you've been at the forefront of saying that we need to turn over Iraq to the Iraqis, and the faster we do it the better off everybody's going to be, and the more of a success this is going to be. I'd like to talk to you just about whether you're concerned at the speed at which that's happened. Back in July, there was a report that the US military put out, just explaining the progress in training Iraqi forces.
理查德·珀尔，你一直站在前线说我们需要把伊拉克移交给伊拉克人，而且越快越好，这样成功率就会越高。我想和你谈谈你是否对这件事情发生的速度感到担忧。早在七月份，美国军方就发布了一份报告，解释训练伊拉克部队的进展。
And a mainstream bi-partisan think tank, the Center for Strategic and International Studies, put out a report. Anthony Cordesman was the author. And it said the US failed to treat the Iraqis as partners in the counterinsurgency effort until April 2004, nearly a year after the fall of Saddam Hussein and 2/3 of a year after major insurgency problems began to emerge. The report reveals massive shortfalls in weapons, vehicles, communications, and body armor. Iraqi forces have about 40% of their minimum weapons needs, about 25% of the necessary body armor.
一个主流的两党智库——战略与国际研究中心——发布了一份报告。安东尼·科德斯曼是作者。报告说，在2004年4月之前，即萨达姆·侯赛因倒台近一年、主要叛乱问题开始出现的三分之二年后，美国未能将伊拉克人视为反叛乱努力的合作伙伴。报告揭示了武器、车辆、通讯和防弹衣的巨大短缺。伊拉克部队的武器需求仅满足了约40%，必要的防弹衣仅满足了约25%。
As of July 13th, the US had spent only $220 million of the $2.9 billion, that is $220 million of the $2.9 billion, dedicated to the Iraqi security forces. No single mission is more important than security and no Iraqi popular desire is clearer than that this mission be done by Iraqis. The US has been guilty of a gross military, administrative, and moral failure. Do you agree with that?
截至7月13日，美国在专门用于伊拉克安全部队的29亿美元资金中仅花费了2.2亿美元，也就是29亿中的2.2亿。没有比安全更重要的任务，也没有比这项任务由伊拉克人来完成更明确的伊拉克民众愿望了。美国犯下了重大的军事、行政和道德失败。你同意这一点吗？
I do agree with that, yes. I do agree with that. Now, having said that, when you look at the source of some of the difficulties, it's pretty appalling. For example, efforts to get equipment into the hands of the Iraqi security forces were frequently frustrated by the impossible procurement procedures that are written into law within the US government.
我确实同意这一点，是的。我同意这一点。话虽如此，当你查看一些困难的根源时，它非常糟糕。例如，为伊拉克安全部队提供装备的努力经常受到美国政府内部法律规定的不可逾越的采购程序的阻碍。
And is this something that you think that the administration, if it had decided to yell and scream about a little bit more and used the force of the power of the presidency more, could have done something about?
这是你认为如果行政部门多吵闹一点，并利用总统权力的强制力，本可以做点什么的事情吗？
Well, Don Rumsfeld, the Secretary of Defense, went to Congress and he asked for some unencumbered funds so that he would have the flexibility to do that sort of thing, and it was turned down.
好吧，国防部长唐·拉姆斯菲尔德去国会申请了一些不受限制的资金，以便他有灵活性来做这类事情，但被拒绝了。
But that's an entirely Republican Congress and Senate.
但那是一个完全由共和党控制的国会和参议院。
Well unfortunately, they're not in that kind of complete control.
不幸的是，他们并没有那种完全的控制权。
Richard Perle, clearly you think that a lot of things have gone wrong. Do you think people should have been fired?
理查德·珀尔，很明显你认为很多事情都出了问题。你认为有人应该被解雇吗？
Oh, I think there are people who should have, yes. But we never fire anybody in this government. Never. Actually, they tend to get promoted.
哦，我认为确实有应该被解雇的人。但我们在这个政府中从来不解雇任何人。从来没有。实际上，他们往往会得到晋升。
James Fallows.
詹姆斯·法洛斯。
Well, you would think there would be someone who would be publicly held to some kind of account for this. Clearly political decisions about the size, the timing, and the makeup of this invasion force have had rippling effects we're feeling to this day. And political leaders are usually held accountable for the effects of their decision.
好吧，你会以为会有人为此公开承担某种责任。显然，关于这次入侵部队的规模、时机和组成的政治决策产生了我们至今仍能感受到的连锁反应。政治领导人通常要为他们决策的结果负责。
James Fallows, you've written about national security professionals, most of them Republicans who you've talked to over the course of two years. I'm just going to read from one of your articles. You say, let me tell you my gut feeling, a senior figure at one of America's military-sponsored think tanks told me recently. In my view, we are much, much worse off now than when we went into Iraq.
詹姆斯·法洛斯，你写过关于国家安全专业人员的文章，其中大多数是你两年来谈过话的共和党人。我只想读你其中一篇文章中的一段。你说：“让我告诉你我的直觉，”一位美国军事赞助的智库的高级人物最近告诉我，“在我看来，我们现在的处境比进入伊拉克时要糟糕得多。”
That is not a partisan position. I voted for these guys, but I think they're incompetent, and I have a very close perspective on what's happening. Certainly in the long run we've harmed ourselves. We are playing to the enemy's political advantage. Whatever tactical victories we may gain along the way, this may prove to be a strategic blunder. Richard Perle, what's your reaction to that?
这不是党派立场。我投了这些人的票，但我认为他们无能，我对正在发生的事情有非常近距离的视角。当然，从长远来看，我们伤害了自己。我们是在为敌人的政治利益服务。无论我们在过程中可能取得什么样的战术胜利，这都可能被证明是一个战略失误。理查德·珀尔，你对此有何反应？
I don't agree with it. I don't know who said it, but I certainly don't agree with it. I don't have any evidence that supports that. I know it is commonly believed that our intervention in Iraq has been a recruitment tool. There is no question that terrorists from around the globe are converging on Iraq. But showing that they have been recruited on the basis of Iraq is another matter altogether.
我不同意。我不知道是谁说的，但我肯定不同意。我没有任何证据支持这一点。我知道人们普遍认为我们对伊拉克的干预是一种招募工具。毫无疑问，来自全球的恐怖分子正在向伊拉克汇聚。但证明他们是以伊拉克为基础被招募的是另一回事。
James Fallows?
詹姆斯·法洛斯？
Most of the people who have spent their lives trying to understand the sources of Islamic terrorism have said that what the US has done in Iraq is increasing their recruitment power. The famous International Institute of Strategic Studies report a couple months ago saying that since the US went to Iraq, the worldwide supply of Al Qaeda operatives is up by a factor of two to three. So we've killed them off inside Iraq but we're creating more, as even Donald Rumsfeld said in one of his memos a year or so ago.
大多数一生都在试图理解伊斯兰恐怖主义根源的人都说，美国在伊拉克的所作所为正在增强他们的招募能力。国际战略研究所几个月前的那份著名报告说，自从美国进入伊拉克以来，全球基地组织人员的供应量增加了两到三倍。所以我们在伊拉克内部消灭了他们，但我们正在制造更多的恐怖分子，正如唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德在大约一年前的一份备忘录中所说的那样。
Well, he raised the question. And I'm impressed that the IISS is able to count the number of Al Qaeda terrorists. I wish they'd tell us now where they are.
他提出了这个问题。而且我对国际战略研究所能够计算基地组织恐怖分子的数量感到印象深刻。我希望他们现在能告诉我们他们在哪里。
The conversation went around and around like this. Both Perle and Fallows thought that there had been profound and preventable mistakes at two of the most important jobs in Iraq: securing the country the day after the invasion and creating and training an Iraqi security force. Perle says these aren't the kinds of things you blame a president for. Fallows quoted chapter and verse about people fired and reports thrown away that could have prevented it.
谈话就这样反反复复。珀尔和法洛斯都认为在伊拉克两个最重要的工作上出现了深重且可以预防的错误：入侵后次日确保国家安全，以及建立和训练伊拉克安全部队。珀尔说这些不是你责怪总统的那种事情。法洛斯引经据典地谈到被解雇的人和被丢弃的报告，而这些本可以防止这种情况。
[MUSIC - "I GIVE UP" BY QUASI]
[音乐 - QUASI的《I GIVE UP》]
Act two, Confession. We turn now to stories about people who are operating behind enemy lines in one way or another. And we begin with the story of a young priest who is sent out on a series of jobs by church administrators to squelch some problems. In spending time out among the people who he is supposed to be deceiving he finds it harder and harder to keep doing his job. Carl Marziali tells the story from Los Angeles.
第二幕，《忏悔》。我们现在转向关于以某种方式在敌后工作的人们的故事。我们从一位年轻牧师的故事开始，他被教会管理者派去处理一系列工作以平息一些问题。在与那些他本应欺骗的人待在一起的过程中，他发现自己越来越难继续他的工作。卡尔·马齐亚利从洛杉矶讲述这个故事。
Patrick Wall was just where he wanted to be at 26. He was a monk studying theology at Saint John's Monastery in rural Minnesota. He lived in a quiet room facing the lake. He looked forward to a life of study and prayer. It was late summer, 1991.
帕特里克·沃尔26岁时正是他想待的地方。他是一位在明尼苏达州农村圣约翰修道院学习神学的修士。他住在一间面向湖泊的安静房间里。他期待着一种学习和祈祷的生活。那是1991年夏末。
The first day that school started out, pretty uneventful winter morning. Prayer at 7 o'clock like normal. Went down for breakfast like normal, went back up to my room. Was literally brushing my teeth when there was a knock on my door, which is extremely out of the ordinary.
开学的第一天，是个非常平静的冬日早晨。7点钟像往常一样祈祷。像往常一样下去吃早餐，又回到我的房间。我正在刷牙时，有人敲我的门，这极其反常。
And it was Abbott Jerome Tyson. Well, the abbot's a very quiet guy, and he usually never went up on that floor of the monastery. So he says, may I come in? I said, yes, Father Abbot, no problem. So he comes in, sits down, and you know I've got my books out, I've got a class in 10 minutes. You know, what's up?
那是杰罗姆·泰森院长。好吧，院长是个很安静的人，他通常从不去修道院的那一层。所以他说，我可以进来吗？我说，是的，院长神父，没问题。于是他进来，坐下，你知道，我把书拿出来，10分钟后有课。你知道，怎么了？
And he said, well, Father Dan Ward has told me that you would be a good person for this particular job. And we have a situation over in Saint Mary's Hall that we need you to be a faculty resident.
他说，嗯，丹·沃德神父告诉我你会是这份特定工作的合适人选。我们在圣玛丽堂有个情况，我们需要你去做驻校教师。
The faculty resident is the live-in counsellor at the college dorm. The campus at Saint John's includes a university.
驻校教师是大学宿舍里的住校顾问。圣约翰校园包括一所大学。
I said, "I'd love to be a faculty resident someday. I think it's a great idea." And he said, "No, today." And when I asked Abbot Jerome specifically what it was for, what was going on, he said well, I can't tell you that.
我说：“有一天我很乐意做驻校教师。我觉得这是个好主意。”他说，“不，今天。”当我问杰罗姆院长具体是为什么，发生了什么事时，他说嗯，我不能告诉你。
We had numerous sexual abuse cases that have been popping up. So ultimately there's only one conclusion that can be drawn. That there was a an allegation that they must have thought somewhat credible or probable, and they needed to pull that particular monk. And off I went.
我们有许多性虐待案件不断涌现。所以最终只能得出一个结论：有一个指控他们一定认为相当可信或有可能，他们需要调走那个特定的修士。于是我就出发了。
That afternoon, Wall moved his stuff out of his room and into the freshman dorm. His instructions were simple. Put the kids at ease, and don't say anything about the monk you're replacing.
那天下午，沃尔把他的东西从房间搬到了新生宿舍。他的指令很简单：让孩子们安心，并且不要说关于他要接替的那个修士的任何事情。
He organized a pizza party for the students. He told them he was taking over as faculty resident but that he couldn't say why. There were no questions. Wall didn't know it then, but he was being tested. Unfortunately for him, he passed. His dream was to be a monk as he understood monks to be: devout and learned men who live in monasteries.
他为学生们组织了一个披萨派对。他告诉他们他是来接任驻校教师的，但他不能说原因。没有人问问题。沃尔当时不知道，他正在接受考验。不幸的是，他通过了。他的梦想是成为一个他所理解的修士：生活在修道院里的虔诚且博学的人。
By showing a knack for damage control, he put himself on a less spiritual path. Before long the abbot appointed him to a sexual abuse response team and sent him to the Church of Saint Elizabeth's in the town of Hastings. He was replacing a pastor who'd been withdrawn for what the monastery called a credible allegation. Wall arrived at Saint Elizabeth's on February 2nd, 1993.
通过展示出处理危机的本领，他让自己走上了一条不太神圣的道路。不久之后，院长任命他加入一个性虐待响应小组，并把他派往黑斯廷斯镇的圣伊丽莎白教堂。他要接替一位因修道院所说的“可信指控”而被撤职的牧师。沃尔于1993年2月2日到达圣伊丽莎白教堂。
Replacing a pastor is not easy. People in a parish tend to get attached to their priest. Replacing a disgraced pastor is harder. A lot of people believe their priest can do no wrong and they are not shy about telling his replacement.
接替一位牧师并不容易。教区的人往往会对他们的牧师产生依恋。接替一位名誉扫地的牧师更难。很多人相信他们的牧师不会做错事，他们毫不犹豫地告诉他的接替者。
They were very forward and forthright and angry. And they said, Father, I'm really sad that you're here. I'm really sorry that you had to come. Because we really liked the other monk and we don't think he should have been removed.
他们非常直接、坦率且愤怒。他们说，神父，我真的很伤心你在这儿。我真的很遗憾你不得不来。因为我们真的很喜欢原来的那个修士，我们不认为他应该被撤职。
And that was it. I said, I'm really sorry that that particular monk had to be removed and I'm here because my abbot asked me to be here. I tried to be as candid and simple as possible, but I felt taken aback, and I felt sad from the very beginning. I didn't enjoy that experience.
就是这样。我说，我很遗憾那个修士不得不被撤职，我在这里是因为我的院长要求我在这里。我尽可能表现得坦诚和简单，但我感到惊讶，从一开始我就感到很难过。我不享受那种经历。
At first, Wall tried to raise morale. He told parishioners what he himself had been told. That the alleged abuse took place A, some time ago, and B, somewhere else. But it wasn't long before victims at Saint Elizabeth's began coming forward. They would show up unannounced at the rectory, or in the church after mass, and asked to speak to him in private. Then they would start with a tiny revelation.
起初，沃尔试图提高士气。他告诉教区居民他自己被告知的事情：涉嫌虐待的事情发生在A，很久以前，以及B，别的地方。但没过多久，圣伊丽莎白教堂的受害者就开始站出来了。他们会不请自来地出现在牧师住宅，或者弥撒后的教堂里，请求私下与他交谈。然后他们会以一个微小的揭露开始。
It's unforgettable. It's absolutely unforgettable when they start to tell you. And they only tell you very small, cryptic little things. There are code words for everything. And they've kind of broached the subject to see what you're going to do with it and to see if you're going to actually believe them.
那是令人难忘的。当他们开始告诉你的时候，绝对是令人难忘的。而且他们只告诉你非常小、隐晦的小事。一切都有代码。他们以某种方式试探这个话题，看看你会怎么处理，看看你是否真的会相信他们。
And obviously I'm 27 years old, I'm not exactly sure what to do with it. Emotionally I really had no idea what to do with it.
显然我当时27岁，我不确定该怎么处理。在情感上，我真的不知道该怎么办。
So how did you deal with it when the victim or victims came forward and told you about what had happened? Do you try to comfort them, do you try to tell them that-- I mean, what do you do? Do you try to restore their faith in the Church or do you just listen and write up a complaint and send it off?
那么，当受害者站出来告诉你发生了什么事时，你是怎么处理的？你试着安慰他们吗？你试着告诉他们——我是说，你做什么？你是试图恢复他们对教会的信仰，还是只是听听并写下投诉然后送走？
You don't even write up a complaint. Basically, you get a few of the facts and then you pass that on to the diocese. And honestly, unfortunately, it's easy to deal with because these people never go to church again. Because they really view that person as representing God, so it's hard for them to publicly ever celebrate or to practice their faith again. So they just disappear, honestly.
你甚至不需要写下投诉。基本上，你获得一些事实，然后将其传递给教区。坦率地说，不幸的是，这很容易处理，因为这些人再也不会去教堂了。因为他们真的把那个人视为代表上帝，所以他们很难再公开庆祝或实践他们的信仰。所以真的，他们只是消失了。
Did you ever wonder whether you should make a special effort when they came to you to-- beyond the effort that you might make to convince somebody else to come back to the church-- to do something more for these victims, or to offer them counseling, or something to try to make up for what had happened?
你有没有想过，当他们来找你时，你应该做出特别的努力——除了你可能用来劝说别人回到教会的努力之外——为这些受害者做更多的事情，或者为他们提供咨询，或者做些什么来弥补已经发生的事情？
It's a difficult situation because you really need to remain neutral. And your natural inclination, especially as priests, is to be sympathetic and to heal. But there's no way that you're going to be allowed to be part of the healing process, because ultimately you're part of the defendant. You are the institution that brought about their hurt. And so you really have to put your professional hat on and keep an arm's distance.
这是一个困难的情况，因为你真的需要保持中立。而你自然的倾向，尤其是作为牧师，是同情和治愈。但你不可能被允许参与治愈过程，因为最终你是被告的一部分。你就是那个造成他们伤害的机构。所以你真的必须戴上职业帽子，保持距离。
Wall survived the scandal at Saint Elizabeth's, and he helped his superiors survive it too. He never told parishioners about the allegations in their parish, and the stories he was hearing in private never became public.
沃尔在圣伊丽莎白教堂的丑闻中幸存了下来，他也帮助他的上司幸存了下来。他从未告诉教区居民关于他们教区里的指控，他在私下里听到的故事也从未公开。
After serving a year at Saint Elizabeth's, Wall thought he would come back to the monastery. But near the end of his term he received a letter from the abbot instructing him to report to another parish, Saint Bernard's. The monk there had been having an affair and paying for it with church money. This was not the assignment Wall had in mind, but part of him was flattered.
在圣伊丽莎白教堂服务了一年后，沃尔以为他会回到修道院。但在任期快结束时，他收到院长的信，指示他前往另一个教区——圣伯纳德教堂。那里的修士一直有婚外情，并用教会的钱来买单。这不是沃尔心目中的任务，但他的一部分感到受宠若惊。
I felt pretty good about it because all of a sudden, I'm 28 years old, I'm an administrator of a parish. I'm being turned loose as the boss. That's a compliment as far as I'm concerned. I really felt I was doing the right thing.
我感觉很好，因为突然间，我28岁，我是教区的管理员。我被放出来当老板了。就我而言，那是一个恭维。我真的觉得我在做正确的事。
Not long after Wall arrived at Saint Bernard's, an agent from the IRS knocked on his door. The agent presented a bill, payable immediately, for $600,000 in back taxes, interest, and penalties for undeclared profits from a church-run lottery. The business manager was not available to answer questions because he had been the other person in the affair and had been removed along with the monk. Wall had to take a crash course in bookkeeping to pay the IRS.
沃尔到达圣伯纳德教堂后不久，国税局的一名探员敲了他的门。探员出示了一张必须立即支付的60万美元账单，包括欠税、利息和罚款，原因是教会经营的彩票未申报利润。业务经理无法回答问题，因为他就是那场婚外情的另一方，已经和那个修士一起被撤职了。沃尔不得不参加簿记速成班来支付国税局。
The rest of his time at Saint Bernard's, Wall did what every priest does. He celebrated Mass, performed weddings and funerals, baptized babies. And he heard confessions, including those of other priests.
在圣伯纳德教堂的其余时间里，沃尔做了每个牧师都会做的事：他主持弥撒，举行婚礼和葬礼，为婴儿洗礼。他还听取忏悔，包括其他牧师的忏悔。
Despite the headlines, the percentage of priests who have abused minors is relatively low. Celibacy is another story. In a recent Los Angeles Times poll, only 1/3 of priests said they do not waver from the celibate life. After a while, Wall stopped thinking of broken vows as something foreign to his world.
尽管头条新闻不断，虐待未成年人的牧师比例相对较低。独身主义是另一回事。在最近《洛杉矶时报》的一项民意调查中，只有三分之一的牧师表示他们不会动摇独身生活。过了一段时间，沃尔不再认为违背誓言是与他的世界无关的事情。
Once you see enough people fall and once you hear enough confessions of different priests, you look at yourself in the mirror and you say, "Am I really any different?" And the chances of me maintaining a celibate way of life without failure along the way are so low that ultimately, either I have to change or the system needs to change.
一旦你看到足够多的人堕落，一旦你听到足够多牧师的忏悔，你就会照镜子对自己说：“我真的有什么不同吗？”而我在没有失败的情况下维持独身生活的机会太小了，以至于最终，要么我必须改变，要么系统必须改变。
What about-- there must a lot of priests who believe in being priests and have decided that the rule of celibacy is nonsense and so are willing to lead a double life of sorts. Was that-- that wasn't something that you considered?
关于——一定有很多牧师相信做牧师，并决定独身规则是无稽之谈，所以愿意过一种双重生活。那——那不是你考虑的事情吗？
No, that's really not my personality. I'm a terrible liar. Oh, I turn red. I'm really bad. And I had seen priests who maintained heterosexual relationships with women and I saw the effects of it. Because it's a life of contradiction, because the relationship is there, it's exclusive, but you can't profess it and everyone around you knows it's going on. And that's not happiness. That's not a true coming together. I just couldn't see myself doing that. That's just not me.
不，那真的不是我的性格。我是个糟糕的撒谎者。哦，我会脸红。我真的很烂。我见过维持与女性异性恋关系的牧师，我看到了它的影响。因为它是一种矛盾的生活，因为关系存在，它是排他的，但你不能公开它，周围每个人都知道它正在进行。那不是幸福。那不是真正的结合。我只是无法想象自己那样做。那不是我。
After Saint Bernard's, the assignments kept coming. The next one was an affair between a priest and a nun. After that, a new parish where a teacher had abused a student and the priest was living with his housekeeper.
在圣伯纳德教堂之后，任务不断接踵而至。下一个是牧师和修女之间的私情。在那之后，是一个新的教区，老师虐待了学生，而牧师和他的管家住在一起。
Four years, four parishes, four scandals. There are good, dedicated priests out there, but they're not the ones who get replaced. By the very nature of his job, Wall was acquiring a skewed and depressing view of the priesthood.
四年，四个教区，四个丑闻。外面有优秀的、敬业的牧师，但他们不是被撤职的那些人。由于他工作的本质，沃尔正在获得一种对牧师职位的扭曲和令人沮丧的看法。
Did you ever ask not to be given those assignments?
你有没有要求不要被委派这些任务？
Yeah, I did. And I specifically asked to be able to come back to the prep school and teach. But the needs of the monastery were so great at that point that again, it was only going to be another year. I was only going to have to go to Saint Bernard's for another year. So it sounds like a bad construction deal, you know, two more weeks. Give me two more weeks and we'll be done. It just kept going on, kept going on.
是的，我有。我特别要求能回到预科学校教书。但当时修道院的需求太大了，所以同样，那只会是又一年。我只需要再去圣伯纳德教堂一年。听起来像个糟糕的建筑交易，你知道，“再给我两周，我们就能搞定了。”它只是不断进行，不断进行。
Meanwhile, the monks he replaced were getting exactly what Wall himself had asked for. They were going back to the monastery, permanently.
与此同时，他接替的那些修士得到了沃尔自己所要求的：他们回到了修道院，永久地。
I'd run across them at community meetings and whenever we had chapter votes, and all that. And it's hard not to be judgmental. The other thing I found hard was that my whole career path was driven by other people's mistakes.
我在社区会议上会碰到他们，无论我们什么时候有章程投票，等等。很难不进行评判。我发现难的另一件事是，我的整个职业道路都是被别人的错误所驱动的。
And that's the last thing I ever expected a monastic life. I really expected to work in a parish for a year, to go off to grad school, come back, teach, coach football at the university, and to live a pretty darn good life of balance between prayer and teaching and working as a teacher. So they changed my career path, they changed my whole trajectory in life.
而那是我在修道院生活中最没想到的事情。我真的希望在一个教区工作一年，去读研，回来，教书，在大学当橄榄球教练，过一种祈祷、教学和作为老师工作之间平衡的、相当不错的生活。所以他们改变了我的职业道路，他们改变了我整个人生的轨迹。
Without fully realizing it, Wall had been initiated into a brotherhood of priests known informally as fixers, or cleaners. They replaced problem priests, they hide things in the archives, they reassure the faithful. In short, they make it all go away.
在没有完全意识到的情况下，沃尔被引入了一个非正式被称为“清理人”或“清洗者”的牧师兄弟会。他们接替有问题的牧师，他们在档案中隐藏事情，他们安抚信徒。简而言之，他们让一切消失。
Visually, he was perfect for the job. He was barrel chested, a former offensive lineman on the Saint John's football team. He was young and friendly. He was the anti-stereotype of a troubled monk. The abbot couldn't have found a better prospect if he had picked a model out of a catalogue.
从外表上看，他是这份工作的完美人选。他胸膛宽阔，是圣约翰橄榄球队的前进攻锋线队员。他年轻又友好。他是问题修士的反典型。如果院长从目录中挑选一个模特，也找不到比他更好的候选人了。
But Wall did more than just PR. He became familiar with the law of the church called canon law. Specifically, with the different archives canon law sets up for storing and hiding information.
但沃尔不仅仅是做公关。他变得熟悉被称为教会法的法律。具体来说，是教会法为存储和隐藏信息而设立的不同档案。
The first is a historical archives which is just the names, states, people, those kinds of things. Then you have the secret archives.
第一个是历史档案，只是姓名、状态、人员，这类事情。然后你有秘密档案。
The secret archives. I mean, is that literally what they're called? The secret archives? I mean, why were they set up?
秘密档案。我的意思是，那字面意思就是那样吗？秘密档案？我的意思是，它们为什么设立？
They're set up for the protection of individuals. So the bishop has the responsibility to take things that would be considered scandalous, things that might hurt individuals' reputations, and to be able to place them there so they wouldn't easily be exposed.
它们是为了保护个人而设立的。所以主教有责任将那些会被认为丑闻的、可能会伤害个人名誉的事情，放置在那里，这样它们就不会轻易暴露。
OK. When you call it the secret archives, though, it makes it sound sinister. It makes it sound like it's there for the protection, to really protect the church. I'm not saying that's what it is, but that's how it sounds. What really is the purpose of these so called secret-- why can't everything be in the personnel records and then some items be labeled confidential or whatever?
好的。然而，当你称之为秘密档案时，它听起来很阴险。听起来它是为了保护而设立的，是为了真正保护教会。我不是说那就是它所代表的意思，但听起来就是这样。这些所谓的秘密档案到底目的是什么——为什么不能一切都在人事记录中，然后有些项目标记为机密或什么的？
Well, you've got to give Rome credit, I mean they have wonderful procedure. This is things that have worked out for centuries. And that has always been the secret to one of the defenses of the Church. If you don't know what you're asking for, they don't have to produce it.
好吧，你得给罗马记功，我的意思是他们有很棒的程序。这是几个世纪以来行之有效的事情。这一直是教会防御的秘密之一。如果你不知道你要找什么，他们就不必提供。
When you were working for the Church cleaning up these situations of abuse and having to tell parishioners some of the facts, but not all of the facts, about what was going on, did you ever feel complicit in the cover-up of all of this?
当你为教会清理这些虐待情况，并不得不告诉教区居民部分事实，而不是全部事实时，你有没有觉得在这一切的掩盖中自己也是共犯？
I have some regrets, but I think I did it in good faith. Because, as I was taught and as I believe, that that was my role, to help the Church in the long run and to be obedient to what I was asked to do. And it's only later on that, as I've had greater experience, that I couldn't support it any longer.
我有一些遗憾，但我认为我是在真诚地做这件事。因为，正如我被教导的和我所相信的，那是我的角色，从长远来看帮助教会，并服从我被要求做的事情。只是后来，随着我有了更多的经验，我再也无法支持它了。
And I felt that if I was going to stay, I was going to not only support it but I was going to get deeper into it. I was going to be asked to do other assignments, to follow pedophiles. I was going to be asked to be on the finance council to try to figure out ways to mitigate the huge financial cost of childhood sexual abuse by priests and the religious.
我觉得如果我还要留下来，我不仅要支持它，还要深入其中。我会被要求做其他的任务，去跟踪恋童癖者。我会被要求进入财务委员会，去想办法减轻由牧师和宗教人士造成的儿童性虐待带来的巨大财务成本。
And I remember having an epiphany and sitting on the porch at Saint Mary's in Stillwater. And that's why I came to the conclusion that this is pretty much going to be my career path. I'd be there for another year or two as the administrator, and then I would go on to another assignment. And I just couldn't do it any longer.
我记得在斯蒂尔沃特的圣玛丽门廊上有一个顿悟。这就是为什么我得出结论，这几乎将成为我的职业道路。我会在那里再做一两年管理员，然后我会去下一个任务。我再也做不下去了。
After four years of deceiving the faithful about the extent of priests and misconduct, of protecting the institution over the health and welfare of the victims, of covering for the perpetrators and letting the problem fester, Patrick Wall decided he was on the wrong side. On July 31st, 1998, Wall quit the priesthood. He was 33 years old.
在欺骗信徒关于牧师不当行为的程度、为了机构利益牺牲受害者的健康和福利、掩盖肇事者并任由问题恶化四年后，帕特里克·沃尔决定他站在了错误的一边。1998年7月31日，沃尔退出了牧师职位。他33岁。
Leaving was difficult. If you want to leave honorably, you need permission, which doesn't come easily or quickly. It took more than a year in Wall's case. Then, once you're out, there are practical challenges, like trying to get a job with a master of theology on your resume. In the end, it was his experience as a fixer that translated best to the real world. Wall read an Op-Ed in the LA Times by John Manley, an attorney who sues the Church on behalf of sexual abuse victims.
离开很困难。如果你想体面地离开，你需要许可，这并不容易或迅速。在沃尔的情况下，花了一年多的时间。然后，一旦你出来了，就有实际的挑战，比如试着在简历上写着神学硕士学位找工作。最终，他在真实世界中最适用的是他作为清理人的经验。沃尔读了一篇《洛杉矶时报》上的专栏文章，作者是约翰·曼利，一位代表性虐待受害者起诉教会的律师。
He essentially separated himself amongst all the different attorneys in saying that we need to protect the sheep, and not the shepherd. It's not the problem of the victims, it's not the problem of the particular perpetrators, per se, or some particular issue like homosexuality or whatever. The problem is within the institution itself.
他本质上在所有不同的律师中脱颖而出，他说我们需要保护羊群，而不是牧羊人。这不是受害者的问题，不是肇事者本身的问题，或者像同性恋或什么的某种特定问题。问题存在于机构本身之中。
By this point, Wall was convinced that lawsuits were the only way to reform the Church. He called Manley and offered to help. Soon they were on the phone constantly. Wall took him step by step through Church bureaucracy. Manley was amazed.
到这个时候，沃尔坚信诉讼是改革教会的唯一途径。他给曼利打了电话并主动提出帮助。很快他们就开始频繁通话。沃尔一步步带他了解教会官僚机构。曼利很惊讶。
John didn't know all the different documents that are out there. And then John would be working on things and he'd call me up and say, "Dude, what do I do with this? What does this mean? Where am I supposed to do with it? What are other things-- where else can I look?"
约翰不知道外面有那么多不同的文件。然后约翰会处理一些事情，他会打给我说：“伙计，我该拿这个怎么办？这是什么意思？我该把它放到哪儿？还有什么——我还能去哪儿找？”
And I remember, I think he was quite surprised when I showed him the penal code of canon law and exactly what we need to ask for. He just couldn't believe that it was there. That they would have that level of sophistication.
我记得，我想当我向他展示教会法刑法典以及我们具体需要申请什么时，他非常惊讶。他简直不敢相信它竟然存在。他们竟然有那种复杂程度。
Wall started working for Manley's law firm full time in October of 2002. Using his knowledge of Latin and Italian, he translates and interprets church records. He helps the firm identify and request key documents, like psychological assessments of priests, from the secret archives. The fact that he switched sides, that he's fighting the Church, doesn't seem to trouble him. He believes he's doing what God wants him to do, which is what he's always believed.
沃尔在2002年10月开始全职为曼利的律师事务所工作。利用他的拉丁语和意大利语知识，他翻译和解读教会记录。他帮助律师事务所识别并从秘密档案中索要关键文件，例如牧师的心理评估。他倒戈、他对抗教会的事实似乎并没有困扰他。他相信他在做上帝想要他做的事，这也是他一直以来所相信的。
There's another part to Wall's job at the firm, which doesn't have anything to do with case law. Last week, he stayed on the phone with a man for an hour and a half, listening to him talk about the priest who abused him and who might still be hurting other people. Wall finds himself talking to victims about all kinds of things, everything he was not allowed to talk about before, back when he was a priest.
沃尔在律师事务所的工作还有另一部分，这与判例法无关。上周，他和一个男人在电话里待了一个半小时，听他谈论那个虐待他的牧师，而那个牧师可能还在伤害其他人。沃尔发现自己和受害者谈论各种各样的事情，所有他在以前当牧师时被禁止谈论的事情。
I feel I really do pastoral work when I'm working with victims every day. On every single issue.
我觉得我在每天与受害者合作时确实在做牧养工作。在每一个问题上。
Before you were part of a holy order, and now you're working with a bunch of lawyers. And it's hard to know these days where priests belong on the ethical ladder, but most people know exactly where to put lawyers, and so it's just odd to hear you talk about this work being more fulfilling in some ways than what you were doing before.
以前你是圣职人员的一部分，现在你和一群律师一起工作。如今很难知道牧师在道德阶梯上属于哪里，但大多数人确切地知道把律师放在哪里，所以听到你说这份工作在某些方面比以前做的事情更有成就感真的很奇怪。
Well, we're dealing with people at the lowest ebb of where they're at. They're dealing with the greatest pain they've ever experienced. And one of the greatest things that we find is that they can no longer participate in sacramental life of the Church because of the seven sacraments.
好吧，我们处理的是处于生活最低谷的人。他们正在处理他们经历过的最大的痛苦。我们发现最重要的事情之一是，他们因为七圣事而再也不能参与教会的圣事生活。
The one thing that's really clear is that it takes a priest to administer the sacrament. And every sacrament is either through touching or it's through breath, through words. It's in close proximity to the priest. And that is the symbol of their abuse. So we're dealing with some of the most damaged people within the Church. And it's a very fulfilling ministry, I find in being pastoral, to be with them. Because honestly, we're one of the few symbols of hope that they have.
真正明确的一点是，需要牧师来施行圣事。每一项圣事要么是通过触摸，要么是通过呼吸、通过话语。它是在靠近牧师的地方。而那正是他们被虐待的象征。所以我们正在处理教会内一些受损最严重的人。我发现成为牧师并在他们身边是非常令人满足的。因为说实话，我们是他们拥有的为数不多的希望象征之一。
Patrick Wall is married now. He and his wife have a two-year-old daughter, who they plan to send to Catholic school. They all go to mass every Sunday.
帕特里克·沃尔现在结婚了。他和妻子有一个两岁的女儿，他们打算把她送进天主教学校。他们每周日都去参加弥撒。
Carl Marziali attends mass with his family in Los Angeles.
卡尔·马齐亚利在洛杉矶和他的家人一起参加弥撒。
Coming up, Enemies on our Turf. Controlling the minds of ants, of rats, and of you and me. This is not some whacked out conspiracy theory, my friend. This is science. Proof in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，《领土上的敌人》。控制蚂蚁、老鼠，以及你我的思想。这不是什么疯狂的阴谋论，我的朋友。这是科学。来自芝加哥公共电台和美国公共广播国际的节目，一分钟后继续。
This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Enemy Camp, stories of what it means to work behind enemy lines. We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, Blood Agent.
《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，并带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目，《敌营》，关于在敌后工作意味着什么的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第三幕。第三幕，《血液代理人》。
Nature, it turns out, is full of enemy agents. Living behind enemy lines, doing their work. Parasites, they're literally parasites. Carl Zimmer has written a book about the different strategies that these parasites use to survive, and it makes for weirdly compelling reading. For one thing, who knew how prevalent they were.
事实证明，大自然充满了敌方特工。生活在敌后，执行着他们的工作。寄生虫，他们确实是寄生虫。卡尔·齐默写了一本关于这些寄生虫用来生存的各种策略的书，读起来有一种怪异的吸引力。首先，谁知道它们如此普遍。
Most creatures on earth are living inside an enemy. And they are trying to fight that enemy, trying to survive, trying to outwit.
地球上大多数生物都生活在一个敌人内部。他们正在试图对抗那个敌人，试图生存，试图智取。
Just to give people a sense of the range of things that different parasites do, could you tell the story of the parasite that gets into ants, the lancet fluke.
为了让人了解不同寄生虫所做事情的范围，你能讲讲进入蚂蚁体内的寄生虫——双盘吸虫的故事吗？
Sure. Well, the lancet fluke is kind of a flatworm. It starts out as an egg on the ground, and a snail comes along and eats the egg. And it kind of irritates the snail's system, so that eventually it kind of coughs it up. And so there you have this sort of clump, kind of snail goo, with the parasite in it. And while it's disgusting to us, to an ant, there's nothing more delicious than snail goo. So the ant comes along and it eats the snail goo and the parasite along with it.
当然。嗯，双盘吸虫是一种扁虫。它最初是地面上的一个卵，蜗牛路过吃掉了这个卵。它会刺激蜗牛的系统，最终把它吐出来。所以你得到了这一团蜗牛粘液，里面有寄生虫。虽然这对我们来说很恶心，但对蚂蚁来说，没有什么比蜗牛粘液更美味的了。所以蚂蚁走过来，吃了蜗牛粘液，也把寄生虫一起吃了下去。
So now you have these flukes inside the ant. And once they recognize that they're inside the ant, they start doing some strange things. As the sun is starting to go down, while the other ants are probably heading back to the nest, it gets this uncontrollable urge to climb upward. It wants to climb up. And what it generally does is it climbs up a blade of grass.
所以现在这些吸虫在蚂蚁体内了。一旦它们意识到它们在蚂蚁体内，它们就开始做一些奇怪的事情。随着太阳开始下山，当其他蚂蚁可能正在回巢时，它产生了一种无法控制的向上攀爬的冲动。它想爬上去。它通常做的是爬上一片草叶。
And what's the advantage to the parasite for the ant to be up there?
这对寄生虫有什么好处，让蚂蚁待在那里？
Well it's not too obvious at first. I mean, it's not like the parasite wants to take in a better view. The thing is that there are these grazing mammals. Sheep, cows. And that's one of their favorite grazing times, towards the end of the day.
嗯，起初并不太明显。我的意思是，这并不是说寄生虫想要看更好的风景。关键是有这些吃草的哺乳动物。绵羊，牛。这是它们最喜欢的吃草时间之一，在一天结束的时候。
So the ant goes up there, sheep comes along, chews on the grass. The ant gets eaten, chewed up, dies. But the flukes inside the ant, they can survive the digestive acids in the sheep's stomach. And actually, sheep are where they like to live. They're their final host.
所以蚂蚁爬上去了，绵羊路过，咀嚼草。蚂蚁被吃掉，嚼碎，死掉。但是蚂蚁体内的吸虫，它们能熬过绵羊胃里的消化酸。事实上，绵羊是它们喜欢居住的地方。它们是它们的最终宿主。
What's so amazing about that is not just the control that the parasite is having over the ant, that life cycle that you're describing is so complicated. It's having to go through three different animals over the course of its normal life cycle.
最令人惊奇的不仅仅是寄生虫对蚂蚁的控制，你所描述的那种生命周期太复杂了。它必须在其正常生命周期内经过三种不同的动物。
Yeah, there are actually some parasites that go through six or seven different animals to get through their life cycle. It's mind boggling.
是的，实际上有些寄生虫要经过六七种不同的动物才能完成它们的生命周期。这太令人难以置信了。
It's really hard to talk about without ascribing a kind of intentionality to them. Which, they don't have consciousness, they don't have brains in any way. It's hard for us to even understand what they're doing without kind of putting that on them.
不赋予它们某种意图就很难谈论。它们没有意识，它们没有任何意义上的大脑。我们很难在不赋予它们那种东西的情况下理解它们在做什么。
Yeah. Because they, I think, because in a sense they are using us. Or are using other animals or other hosts in such an intentional way. And they seem to know so much.
是的。因为它们，我认为，在某种意义上它们正在利用我们。或者以如此刻意的形式利用其他动物或其他宿主。而且它们似乎知道得太多了。
Say, how does a tapeworm inside a fish know that if it makes it flick and flail in a certain way that it will be easier for a bird to see it so they can get inside that bird where it wants to be. It's amazing. And not only do they not have brains, a lot of them don't even have nerves. So it's just this sinister chemical wisdom they have.
说说看，鱼体内的绦虫怎么知道如果它让鱼以某种方式摆动和扭动，鸟类就更容易看到它，这样它就能进入它想要进入的鸟体内。这太神奇了。而且它们不仅没有大脑，它们中的许多甚至没有神经。所以这只是它们拥有的一种邪恶的化学智慧。
It seems like all the parasites break down into two different groups. There are the kinds that actually get inside a host and then kill it off in their drive to survive, and then there are others which actually just kind of live inside and are happily living inside forever. They want the host to survive. Could you just tell the example of the creature that eats the fish's tongue?
看起来所有的寄生虫都分为两组。有些进入宿主体内并在此过程中杀死它，而另一些则是快乐地永远生活在里面。它们希望宿主存活。你能举个吃鱼舌头的生物的例子吗？
Yeah, this is a particularly creepy one. The parasite in question is called an isopod, which is a kind of crustacean. It looks like a little pill bug or something. But it lives in the water.
是的，这是一个特别令人毛骨悚然的例子。这种寄生虫被称为等足类动物，是一种甲壳动物。它看起来像个小药丸虫什么的。但它生活在水里。
And what it does is it swims into the mouth of a snapper, a fish. And when it's in there, it eats that fish's tongue. It just devours the tongue completely, but just the tongue. It stops there. But now this isopod, this parasite, does something very weird. It sort of turns around so it's facing front, and hunkers down exactly where the tongue used to be.
它所做的是游进笛鲷（一种鱼）的嘴里。当它在里面时，它会吃掉那条鱼的舌头。它完全吞噬了舌头，但只是舌头。它到此为止。但现在这个等足类动物，这个寄生虫，做了一些非常奇怪的事情。它转身面向前方，蹲伏在舌头曾经所在的位置。
So if you look in one of these fish's mouths, you see this tongue that has these little eyes on the end of it. It's amazing. And what scientists think then happens is that the fish can then use the parasite as its tongue. And it'll go out and catch some food, catch a fish, and will crush up the food on the back of this parasite. The fish doesn't mind too much if it can still get its meal, I guess. And the fish can then get back to its life.
所以如果你看这些鱼的嘴，你会看到这条舌头，舌头末端有小眼睛。这太神奇了。科学家们认为接下来发生的事情是鱼可以利用寄生虫作为它的舌头。它会出去捕食食物，抓住一条鱼，然后在寄生虫的背上压碎食物。我想如果鱼还能吃到饭，它就不会太介意了。然后鱼就可以继续它的生活了。
So many of these stories just are such gross-out stories on a visceral level.
很多这些故事在直观层面上都是极其恶心的故事。
Well you know, it's funny because it disturbs us when we talk about that when it comes to parasites. But, I mean, why doesn't it disturb us when we talk about a lion. We name football teams after lions, but we don't name football teams after tapeworms. You don't have the Chicago Tapeworms or something that. We don't want to think about it.
嗯，你知道，这很有趣，因为当我们谈到寄生虫时，这会困扰我们。但是，我的意思是，为什么当我们谈论狮子时它不困扰我们？我们以狮子命名橄榄球队，但我们不用绦虫命名橄榄球队。你不会有“芝加哥绦虫”之类的球队。我们不想去想它。
But we admire these predators, but what are these predators doing? These predators are taking advantage of these other life forms. They're eating it from the outside, I guess you could say. But I mean, to my mind, it's just a lot more cool when they're on the inside trying to figure out how to make this work.
但我们钦佩这些捕食者，这些捕食者在做什么？这些捕食者正在利用其他生命形式。我想你可以说它们从外部吃掉它。但我的意思是，在我看来，当它们在内部试图弄清楚如何让这行得通时，这要酷得多。
Thinking about this as much as you have, do you start to see everything as being parasites?
思考了这么多，你开始把一切都视为寄生虫了吗？
I see a lot of things as being like parasites. Parasites are the most successful life form on Earth. And it could be as many as three parasites for every one free living species, it's hard to say. And if you're not a species that is living inside another thing, then you're a species with something living inside of you.
我确实看到很多东西就像寄生虫。寄生虫是地球上最成功的生命形式。可能每一种自由生活的物种就有三种寄生虫，很难说。如果你不是一个生活在别的东西体内的物种，那么你就是一个体内有东西生活的物种。
Is one side winning?
有一方赢了吗？
I'd say the parasites have the upper hand because they're just doing so very well.
我会说寄生虫占据了上风，因为它们做得太好了。
The parasites have the upper hand?
寄生虫占据了上风？
Sure. Yeah. I mean, they have the most species, they're getting around all these defenses. I mean, there are things they do that either we don't know how they do it or if we know how they do it we can't reproduce it. We just stand in awe of it.
当然。是的。我的意思是，它们拥有最多的物种，它们正在绕过所有这些防御。我的意思是，它们做的有些事情，要么我们不知道它们是怎么做的，要么如果我们知道它们是怎么做的，我们也无法重现它。我们只是对它肃然起敬。
I know, but we know about them, they don't know about us. We're the ones with the brains and the thinking and the consciousness.
我知道，但我们了解它们，它们不了解我们。我们是拥有大脑、思想和意识的一方。
Then maybe you're overselling your brain. I mean, the brain is a wonderful thing, but these parasites are able to pull the strings in those brains in a lot of cases. Say, for example, you know, a rat. Rats are very, very smart animals. They know how to learn, they know how to figure out their surroundings.
那么也许你高估了你的大脑。我的意思是，大脑是一个奇妙的东西，但在很多情况下，这些寄生虫能够拉动这些大脑中的琴弦。举个例子，你知道，老鼠。老鼠是非常、非常聪明的动物。它们知道如何学习，它们知道如何弄清楚周围的环境。
But there's a parasite called toxoplasma, it's a single-celled parasite. And they pick it up on the ground. And when it gets into them, they suddenly lose their fear of the smell of cats. Otherwise, they're totally the same. And then the cat eats them, and then toxoplasma gets into its final host, which is the cat. So even though you've got a brain, you're still being pushed toward your doom by this single-celled parasite.
但有一种叫弓形虫的寄生虫，它是一种单细胞寄生虫。它们在地面上捡到它。当它进入它们体内时，它们突然失去了对猫的气味的恐惧。除此之外，它们完全一样。然后猫吃了它们，弓形虫就进入了它的最终宿主——猫。所以即使你有一个大脑，你仍然被这个单细胞寄生虫推向你的厄运。
Mr. Zimmer, whose side are you on?
齐默先生，你站在哪一边？
I think I'm on the parasites' side when it comes to getting a bad rep. I'm their PR man.
当涉及到获得坏名声时，我想我站在寄生虫这一边。我是它们的公关人员。
Because, Mr. Zimmer, at some point we're all going to have to choose sides in this war. Speaking for the other humans, I want to say you're either with us or against us.
因为，齐默先生，在某些时候我们都必须在这场战争中选择阵营。代表其他人，我想说你要么和我们在一起，要么反对我们。
You know, it's funny. I have not gotten seriously sick in my life, knock on wood. And I have actually gone to places where there are a lot of parasites around in order to report on how people are dealing with them. And I didn't get sick. I was really scared, but I didn't get sick. I didn't get malaria, I didn't get river blindness, I didn't get sleeping sickness.
你知道，这很有趣。我一生中还没有生过重病，敲敲木头。我实际上去过有很多寄生虫的地方，以便报道人们是如何应对它们的。我没生病。我真的很害怕，但我没生病。我没得疟疾，没得河盲症，没得昏睡病。
Wait a second. Are you saying this because they could sense that you are in league with them?
等一下。你是这么说是因为它们能感觉到你和它们是一伙的吗？
Who knows. Maybe they think I'm here to serve their purpose.
谁知道呢。也许它们认为我在这里是为了服务它们的目的。
Carl Zimmer. His book, the perfect reading material if you ever want to have a long talk with an eight-year-old boy, is Parasite Rex.
卡尔·齐默。他的书《寄生虫雷克斯》，如果你想和八岁的小男孩长谈，那是完美的阅读材料。
[MUSIC - "I LIVE OFF YOU" BY X-RAY SPEX]
[音乐 - X-RAY SPEX的《I LIVE OFF YOU》]
Act four, Sleeping with your Enemy. We have this story about what's hidden inside of us, the secret agents within. From writer Etgar Keret. Among other things, he says that it's a story about his real-life girlfriend. Actor Matt Malloy reads it for us. A warning to listeners before we begin, this story mentions the existence of sex.
第四幕，《与敌同眠》。我们有一个关于我们内心隐藏着什么——内部秘密特工的故事。来自作家埃特加·凯雷特。除其他事项外，他说这是一个关于他现实生活中女朋友的故事。演员马特·马洛伊为我们阅读它。在开始之前给听众一个警告，这个故事提到了性的存在。
Surprised? Of course I was surprised. You go out with a girl. First date, second date, a restaurant here, a movie there, always just matinees. You start sleeping together, sex is dynamite, and pretty soon there's feeling too.
惊讶吗？我当然很惊讶。你和一个女孩约会。第一次约会，第二次约会，一家餐厅，一部电影，总是只是日场。你们开始睡觉了，性爱是炸药，很快也有了感觉。
And then, one day, she arrives all weepy, and you hug her and tell her to take it easy, that everything's OK, but she says she can't stand it anymore, she has this secret, not just a secret, something really awful, a curse, something she's been wanting to tell you the whole time but she didn't have the guts.
然后，有一天，她泪眼婆娑地来了，你拥抱她告诉她放轻松，一切都好，但她说她再也受不了了，她有个秘密，不仅仅是一个秘密，一些真正可怕的事情，一个诅咒，一些她一直想告诉你但一直没胆量说出来的事情。
This thing, it's been weighing down on her like a ton of bricks and now she's got to tell you, she's simply got to. But she knows that as soon as she does, you'll leave her, and you'd be absolutely right, too. And right after that, she starts crying all over again.
这件事，它像千斤重担一样压在她身上，现在她必须告诉你，她只是必须说。但她知道一旦她说了，你就会离开她，你也会完全正确。在这之后，她又开始哭了起来。
"I won't leave you," you tell her. "I won't. I love you." You may look a little upset, but you're not. And even if you are, it's about her crying, not about her secret.
“我不会离开你的，”你告诉她。“我不会。我爱你。”你可能看起来有点难过，但你没有。即使你有，那也是因为她的哭泣，而不是因为她的秘密。
You know by now that these secrets that always make a woman fall to pieces are usually nothing. And you hug them and say, "It's all right, it's OK." Or "Shh" if they don't stop.
你现在知道，这些总是让女人崩溃的秘密通常什么都不是。你拥抱她们说：“没事，没关系。”或者如果她们不停下来就说“嘘”。
"It's something really terrible," she insists, as if she's picked up on how nonchalant you are about it, even though you tried to hide it. "In the pit of your stomach it may sound terrible," you tell her, "but that's mostly because of the acoustics. Soon as you let it out, it won't seem nearly as bad, you'll see."
“这真的很可怕，”她坚持说，好像她察觉到了你对它有多么漫不经心，尽管你试图隐藏它。“在你的胃部深处它听起来可能很可怕，”你告诉她，“但这主要是因为声学原因。一旦你把它释放出来，它就不会看起来那么糟糕了，你会看到的。”
And she almost believes it. She hesitates a minute and then asks, "What if I told you that at night I turn into a heavy, hairy man, with no neck, with a gold ring on his pinky? Would you still love me?" And you tell her of course you would. What else can you say, that you wouldn't? She's simply trying to test you, to see whether you love her unconditionally. And you've always been a winner at tests.
她几乎相信了。她犹豫了一分钟然后问：“如果我告诉你，在晚上我变成了一个沉重、多毛的男人，没有脖子，小指上戴着金戒指呢？你还会爱我吗？”你告诉她你当然会。你还能说什么，说你不会吗？她只是在试探你，看你是否无条件地爱她。而你一直是个测试赢家。
Truth is, as soon as you say it, she melts, and you screw, right there in the living room. And afterward, you lie there holding each other tight, and she cries, because she's so relieved. And you cry too. Go figure.
事实是，一旦你说出来，她就融化了，你们就在客厅里做爱了。事后，你们躺在那里紧紧拥抱在一起，她哭了，因为她感到如此解脱。你也哭了。去想吧。
And unlike all the other times, she doesn't get up and leave. She stays there and falls asleep. You lie awake looking at her beautiful body, at the sunset outside, at the moon appearing as if out of nowhere, at the silvery light flickering over her body, stroking the hair on her back.
而且不像其他时候，她没有起身离开。她待在那里睡着了。你躺着醒着看着她美丽的身体，看着外面的夕阳，看着月亮好像从无中出现，看着银色的光在她身体上闪烁，抚摸着她背上的毛发。
And within less than five minutes you find yourself lying next to this guy. This short, fat guy. And the guy gets up and smiles at you, and gets dressed awkwardly. He leaves the room and you follow him, spellbound.
不到五分钟，你发现自己躺在这个家伙旁边。这个矮胖的家伙。那个家伙起身对你微笑，笨拙地穿上衣服。他离开房间，你被迷住了一样跟着他。
He's in the den now, his thick fingers fiddling with the remote, zapping to the sports channels. Championship football. When they miss a pass, he curses the TV. When they score, he gets up and does this little victory dance.
他在书房了，他粗短的手指摆弄着遥控器，调到体育频道。冠军足球。当他们错过传球时，他诅咒电视。当他们得分时，他起身跳了那个胜利小舞蹈。
After the game, he tells you that his throat is dry and his stomach is growling. He could really use a beer and a nice hunk of meat. Well done, if possible, with lots of onion rings, but he'd settle for some pork chops too. So you get in the car and take him to this restaurant that he knows about and you don't.
比赛结束后，他告诉你他的喉咙干了，肚子在咕咕叫。他真的很需要啤酒和一大块肉。可能的话，要全熟的，配上很多洋葱圈，但他也满足于一些猪排。所以你上了车，带他去一家他知道而你不知道的餐厅。
This new twist has you worried, it really does, but you have no idea what to do about it. Your command and control centers are down. You shift gears at the exit, in a daze. He's right there beside you in the passenger seat, tapping that gold-ringed pinky of his. At the next intersection, he rolls down his window, winks at you, and yells at this chick who's thumbing a ride, "Hey, baby, wanna play nanny goat and ride in the back?"
这个新转折让你担心，真的，但你不知道该怎么办。你的指挥和控制中心瘫痪了。你在出口处恍惚中换档。他就坐在副驾驶座上，敲打着他那个戴着金戒指的小指。在下一个交叉路口，他降下车窗，对那个竖起大拇指搭便车的妞儿眨眼，喊道：“嘿，宝贝，想玩保姆羊在后面坐吗？”
Later, the two of you pack in the steak and the chops and the onion rings till you're about to explode, and he enjoys every bite, and laughs like a baby. And all that time, you keep telling yourself it's got to be a dream. A bizarre dream, yes, but definitely one that you'll snap out of any minute.
后来，你们两个塞进了牛排、排骨和洋葱圈，直到你们快要爆炸，他享受每一口，像个婴儿一样笑。而那整个时间，你不断告诉自己这一定是个梦。一个离奇的梦，是的，但绝对是你随时会从中醒来的那种。
On the way back, you ask him where to let him off, and he pretends not to hear you, but he looks despondent. So you wind up taking him back home with you. It's almost 3 AM. "I'm going to hit the sack," you tell him, and he waves to you, stays in the beanbag chair, staring at the fashion channel.
在回来的路上，你问他要在哪里让他下车，他假装没听见，但他看起来很沮丧。所以你最终还是带他回了家。快凌晨3点了。“我要去睡觉了，”你告诉他，他向你挥手，留在豆袋椅里，盯着时尚频道。
You wake up the next morning, exhausted, with a slight stomachache. And there she is, in the living room, still dozing. By the time you've had your shower, she's up. She hugs you guiltily, and you're too embarrassed to say anything.
第二天早上你醒来，筋疲力尽，胃有点疼。她就在客厅里，还在打瞌睡。等你洗完澡，她起床了。她愧疚地拥抱你，你太尴尬了，什么也没说。
Time goes by and you're still together. The sex just gets better and better. And she's not so young anymore, and neither are you, and suddenly find yourselves talking about a baby. And at night, you and the fatso guy hit the town like you've never done in your life. He takes you to restaurants and bars you didn't even know existed, and you dance on tables together, break plates like there's no tomorrow.
时间流逝，你们还在一起。性爱变得越来越好。她不再那么年轻了，你也不再年轻，突然发现自己在谈论生孩子。而在晚上，你和那个胖子像你一生中从未做过的那样去城里玩。他带你去你甚至不知道存在的餐厅和酒吧，你们一起在桌子上跳舞，摔盘子好像没有明天。
He's really nice, the fatso guy, a little crass, especially with women, sometimes coming out with things that make you just want to die. But other than that, he's great fun to be with.
他真的很好，那个胖子，有点粗鲁，尤其是对女人，有时说出一些让你想死的话。但除此以外，和他在一起很有趣。
When you first met him, you didn't give a damn about football, but now you know every team. And whenever one of your favorites wins, you feel like you've made a wish and it's come true. Which is a pretty exceptional feeling for someone like you, who hardly knows what he wants most of the time.
当你第一次见到他时，你根本不在乎足球，但现在你知道每一支球队。每当你最喜欢的一支球队赢了，你就会觉得你许了个愿，而它实现了。对于像你这样大部分时间几乎不知道自己想要什么的人来说，这是一种非常特殊的感受。
And so it goes. Every night you fall asleep with him struggling to stay awake for the early scores on ESPN, and in the morning there she is. The beautiful forgiving woman that you love too till it hurts.
事情就是这样。每天晚上你和他一起睡着，他还在努力熬夜看ESPN的早期得分，而早上她就在那里。你深爱到心痛的美丽宽容的女人。
Matt Malloy, reading Etgar Keret's story "Fatso." Keret is the author of a book of short stories called The Bus Driver Who Wanted to be God. His story was translated into English by Miriam Shlesigner. Publishers take note. "Fatso" is part of a book of great short stories, brand new. It is looking for an American publisher.
马特·马洛伊，阅读埃特加·凯雷特的故事《胖子》。凯雷特是短篇小说集《想成为上帝的公交车司机》的作者。他的故事由米里亚姆·施莱辛格翻译成英语。出版商请注意。《胖子》是一本很棒的短篇小说集的一部分，全新的。它正在寻找美国出版商。
Special thanks today to Danny Miller, Jennifer Swihart, Tim Lavin, Bob Carlson, Brett Grossman, Scott Carrier, Peter Gray. Music help from conciliary Sarah Vowell. Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our shows for absolutely free. Or buy CDs of them. You know, you can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife. With a public radio programs best selling books. Even the New York Times, all at audible.com.
今天特别感谢丹尼·米勒、詹妮弗·斯威哈特、蒂姆·拉文、鲍勃·卡尔森、布雷特·格罗斯曼、斯科特·卡里尔、彼得·格雷。音乐帮助来自辅助人员萨拉·沃威尔。我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费收听我们的节目。或者购买它们的CD。你知道，你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们的节目音频。还有公共广播节目最畅销的书籍。甚至是《纽约时报》，都在audible.com。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Funding for our show is provided by Volkswagen of America and the Phaeton, featuring an air suspension system that can be adjusted to one of four performance settings on the fly. The Phaeton, it's the most Volkswagen you can get without a prescription. More at vw.com. WBEZ management oversight for our program by Torey Malatia, who has just one question for you:
《美国生活》由美国公共广播国际发行。我们的节目资金由大众美国公司和辉腾提供，配备了一种可以在飞行中调节为四种性能设置之一的空气悬架系统。辉腾，这是你在没有处方的情况下能得到的最像大众汽车的汽车。更多信息请访问vw.com。WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他只有一个问题要问你：
Hey baby, wanna play nanny goat and ride in the back?
嘿宝贝，想玩保姆羊在后面坐吗？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，美国公共广播国际。